farmers in india are staging a one-day
nationwide strike in protest
over the government's reforms to
agriculture laws
tens of thousands of farmers have been
blockading roads into delhi since the
end of november
demanding the changes be repealed under
the new provisions
state-run purchases will be scrapped
allowing farmers to sell direct to
supermarkets
farmers say they'll be worse off while
the government says the sector needs to
be modernized
for more i'm joined from delhi by dw
india correspondent namisha jaiswal
no namisha farmers say these reforms are
against their interests but the bjp the
government says the new
laws will not hurt farmers who's right
well rebecca at this point it is almost
a matter of perspective the government
is insisting
that they are trying to help farmers but
making changes to
each old government regulated markets
that have been the norm so far
and are flawed in their own ways they're
also saying that they're trying to knock
out middlemen
and allow farmers to access more
competitive pricing
and sell their produce for higher by
allowing them to sell to corporates and
private firms as well
farmers however are very concerned that
once corporates get involved
they can then drive down prices which
eventually ends up hurting the farmers
they also worry that the government may
back off from a guaranteed price
that they have not mentioned in these
form
new farm laws and farmers believe that
as privates and corporates take over the
governments will back out
from their responsibilities leaving
farmers in the lunch
there's a lot of opposition many of the
opposition parties are opposed to this
law as well how determined is the
government to push through the reforms
the government is definitely very
determined despite the fact that there
have been
five rounds of talks that farmers are
blocking off roads
all around the national capital and
insisting that these laws
must be rolled back the government is
standing firm
that they will not hold back these laws
that the government that the farmers
are perhaps being misled now opposition
parties have chimed in
expressing support to a national strike
that was called by the farmers today
this has led the government to react and
call these protests political
the government points out that
opposition parties were in power in the
past or when contesting elections
have actually proposed laws very similar
to the ones that this government has
executed
they also allege that these parties are
now trying to pander to the ever
important voting bank of farmers
well the farmers have had delhi under
siege for almost two weeks and the
pictures we're seeing you can see a lot
of disruption now today's
strike how much support do the farmers
have amongst the general population
well farmers definitely do have support
rebecca when we look at this national
strike
transport unions have supported it there
is an expectation that fruit and
vegetable supplies will be hit
bank unions and other unions that also
express support
however farmers have said that this
protest will only be the strike will
only be
from 11 am to 3 pm local time because
they do not want to disrupt all those
goals
they do not want to inconvenience anyone
they say this is a symbolic protest
especially in the run-up to the sixth
round of talks they will have for the
government tomorrow
right namisha at jayaswal in delhi
thanks very much for the update
you